All right. Good afternoon, and welcome to this educational session
on mechanisms of resistance to targeted IO therapies and
strategies for overcoming resistance.
We have, I think, a really great set of diverse
talks that will cover
how we can leverage the immune system to overcome
resistance to targeted therapy. That will be my talk.
And then Chiara Ambrogio from University of
Torino is going to tell us about
in pathway tumor intrinsic ways to do
combinations, and a lot of beautiful mouse studies
to see which of these combinations are the most therapeutically
beneficial.
And then Silvio Gutkind from here at UC
San Diego will talk about the Hippo-
Yap/Tead pathway, another tumor intrinsic, but
much more developmentally driven pathway that is,
I think, very leverageable for overcoming resistance.
So thank you for being here, and we'll start off
with my talk on mechanisms of resistance to direct RAS
inhibitors and approaches for overcoming resistance.
These are my disclosures, companies that I consult with, that have stock
and cash compensation from.
So
really why I think we're all here in this
room is to try to... We know cancer is a
genetic-driven disease, and it undergoes
evolution in the absence of therapy, as well as
accelerated evolution in the presence of therapy.
And so when random mutations land on
proto-oncogenes, like KRAS, such as the glycine
12 mutation, it drives a signaling pathway that lets the
cell grow in the absence of external growth factors.
Luckily, that single point mutation is not enough to create the tumor
because of the
oncogene-induced stress
triggers tumor suppressor functions like p53, the
transcription factor that transcribes a whole program, a whole
set of genes to block the cell cycle or push the
cell into apoptosis. But that cell is not
growing, but it is in a senescent state, and it is itself subject
to further mutational attack. And when p53, for example,
gets mutated, the brakes come off and the cell is rapidly
undergoing the cell cycle. That rapid
cell division in the absence of normal checkpoints leads to
accumulation of more and more mutations, and these mutations can
be other driver mutations, or they can be just simple passenger
mutations. But once these accumulate enough, then, of course, this
cell looks more and more foreign to the immune system.
And through presentation by class I
MHC of neoantigenic peptides, these
complexes can be recognized by T cells that have T cell
receptors to these foreign peptides.
They're not foreign from a virus, of course, but they're foreign in the sense that
they're not genomically encoded.
So they are this product of somatic mutation inside that tumor
cell. If that recognition happens, the tumor could be eliminated.
But of course, we know that the tumor cell can fight back on the immune
system, upregulating PD-L1 to try to
trigger PD-1, the suppressor, to silence the
T cell, and thereby prevent the immune system from
killing the tumor cell. But luckily, the breakthroughs of immune
oncology and the checkpoint therapies, like
anti-PD-1 or anti-PD-L1, allows us to take those breaks
off and then let the T cell kill the tumor cell.
So this is a
picture of, I think, where we are right now.
We have many inhibitors of the oncogenes, over 100
kinase inhibitors, new KRAS inhibitors that I'll mention a little bit
of, but we'll hear a lot more of at the meeting.
We know tumor suppressor loss is a big driver.
We don't have the best ways to exploit that, except in the case of PARP
inhibitors with BRCA mutations and maybe PRMT5
inhibitors in CDKN2A loss. And a
few bespoke examples. That's a big opportunity, I think,
that would really help us prevent the emergence of resistance.
The point I'd like to make in my talk is that if we can
pick the right kinds of inhibitors of the oncogenes
in the oncogene group and pair that with the right
IO therapies, then we might be able to get more durable
and complete responses. And I'll try to walk through two examples that have
emerged in the literature recently on how to do that, which I think are very
exciting and I'd like to highlight.
So
I know Chiara and I will talk about KRAS, so I want to make sure
that you're all familiar with the RAS cycle.
So GTPases bind to GDP and GTP.
In the GDP state, they are off.
They have two elements, the switch loops here,
switch one and switch two, that are essentially disordered
and in the wrong conformation to stimulate or recruit downstream
effectors like PI3 kinase or BRAF.
But in the GTP state, those switch peptides are
folded and are in the state competent for binding PI3 kinase and
BRAF and turning on the signal. In order to proceed from the
GDP off state to the GTP state, we need a guanine
exchange factor to strip out the nucleotideThe
cell then has higher GTP concentration and loads GTP.
Then the timer on the GTPase is set, and it has two
ways to wind down to the GDP state through a
slow intrinsic hydrolysis or a rapid GTPase
activating protein, a rapid GAP catalyzed hydrolysis.
That turns out to be the key feature that the
mutations at the glycine 12 exploit.
These glycine 12 mutations early on were confusing to people because it
seemed like such a subtle mutation.
Why would a subtle mutation like a glycine have such a big impact on
a protein? The answer turned out to be discovered from
my colleague Frank McCormick, who identified that these glycine 12
mutations work in trans. They disrupt the
gap from stimulating hydrolysis.
Then Fred Vettinghoffer
in Dortmund had realized and solved the co-crystal structure of the
GAP RAS complex, and here you can see the glycine 12
mutation is exactly at the interface pointing at a
catalytically key residue from the gap that accelerates
hydrolysis. So
any residue other than glycine will push the arginine away,
diminishing the gap, and then letting the protein stay in
the GTP state for a much longer time.
And so this turns out to be a fascinating
mutation because there are different spectra of
mutations of alleles that emerge in the different RAS-driven
cancers. These are the 12 most lethal cancers in the US.
In green is incidence, in yellow is mortality.
In blue are the fraction of those patients that have a RAS mutation.
So it's about 30% of lung, about half of colon, almost
90% plus of pancreatic cancer being the prototypical KRAS
driven disease.
As I said, there's a different spectrum of mutations in each of these
diseases. Pancreas, it's dominated by aspartate, then valine, then
cysteine. Colon, it's half aspartate, cysteine
grows in a bit. In the smoking-induced cancer, cysteine in lung
becomes the dominant.
And when you look at the fraction of all of these together, you see
again, aspartate is dominant, valine, and then cysteine.
So
it's
possible, and we know that in many cases, a patient might
present late stage with several of these alleles.
And so there might already be preexisting resistance.
Now, what we're very fortunate to have, I think, are
exquisitely selective inhibitors of KRAS.
These were developed in our lab to target
the cysteine because it's the most attractive chemically.
We can make a covalent bond, an irreversible bond to that
cysteine. It's not the most frequent mutation.
You see it's the third most frequent, but it gives us that chemical
handle to trap the drug onto the complex.
The other feature that I want to stress in this talk is that if it's
selective for cysteine, it does not bind to wild type or any of the other
alleles. So we have an allele-specific inhibitor that should have
a very high therapeutic index because it doesn't target the wild type RAS.
That'll be important in a moment in the immune side of
things. So when we targeted cysteine, we identified a drug that
bound to that cysteine. Here's the cysteine 12.
Here's the nucleotide pocket. Here's the early form of the drug, and
it found a pocket in the protein under the switch two loop,
and that is what we call this pocket, the switch two pocket binders.
And this then served as a starting point to optimize the molecule.
So we reported that in 2013. We converted it into a
cell-active molecule. Our colleagues at Auraxis then
elaborated the molecule more and more to be more specific
until this molecule, reported in 2018, was
able to inhibit
tumor growth in animals. And then a number of other
groups have really elaborated the scaffold and made
active clinical agents until the first two agents, sotorasib
and adagrasib, were approved in 2020 and 2021.
So now we have a number of these agents, and to give you an
idea of what the clinical responses look like, this is the
next
farthest along molecule that is the so-called G12C off
inhibitor, so it binds to cysteine very selectively.
And in the off state, which I won't get into in this talk, but you can
see about 80% disease control. You can see a single
example of a complete response in this waterfall plot, but
then you notice a patient responded, but then had
progressive disease and relapsed.
And that's kind of the summary slide for why we're all here in this session
today, is to really prioritize these kinds
of patients. How can we get better therapies to them
earlier so that their responses become
permanent and more durable?
So
this is sort of where the field is now, and I'd like
to now start to introduce the immune oncology
side of therapies and try to...
Oh, I'm very sorry. Try to put those two together.
So this is the now classic cancer immunity cycle from Ira
Mellman's group at Genentech, where we have a tumor, and
when cells are killed or die naturally in that tumor,
they release these neoantigens. Again, these are those peptides that have the
mutations that are the somatic mutants in the tumor cell.
Antigen-presenting cells capture those, present those, carry them to
lymph nodes, stimulate T cells, educate the T cells so
that these CTLs can then traffic, hone
back to the tumor, and then make an immunological synapse back on the
tumor cell and kill them.So now that we've
got these KRAS inhibitors and patients are on them,
what kinds of effects are we seeing, and what can
we leverage from that knowledge? So the point here is
that we've got a tumor. It has a G12C driver mutation.
We have a selective inhibitor for it.
It has passenger mutations as well, and the immune system can see all
of that, or it can see a subset of that.
It's capable of seeing all of that.
And what's, I think, very attractive about these allele-specific
inhibitors, different than many of the targeted therapies in the kinase
class that we've had, is that when we think about the immunological
synapse, we know that these molecules are
only selective for the tumor cells.
So they spare the T cell and may let the T cell do more
effective killing because we're not inhibiting the T cell's function.
So that's, I think, the promise of it, but getting that to play
out correctly, of course, is a big challenge.
So,
to remind you what immune checkpoint therapy does
on its own and what it requires for the most best responses,
we need many neoantigens. So we need high
tumor mutation burden in order to get the best responses.
And so the earliest responses to checkpoint
therapies were in the far right here, where we
have the highest number of mutations.
These are hundreds to thousands
of mutations per megabase of DNA. So these are chock-full of
new neoantigens for the immune system to see.
So taking the brakes off that, then we can see responses.
But as you can tell, there are many tumors over here
that really don't have enough neoantigens and are poor responders,
we know from the clinic, to single-agent checkpoint therapies.
And we're talking about KRAS here, so I'll highlight where the pancreatic
tumors lie. Very
little of those high tumor mutations in most
tumors. So with these kinds of tumors, where we are in
the RAS field, how do we get more responses?
And I think one of the really nice examples that
emerged in the last few years from the Sloan Kettering group
and Roche Genentech group was to develop
personalized neoantigen mRNA vaccines
in early pancreatic cancer patients,
pair that with checkpoint therapy and standard of care chemotherapy,
post-surgical resection. And I wanted to take you
through that because I think it's a very
promising strategy, although you'll see it is
highly labor and computational and
it's a personalized
strategy, so very difficult on large scale.
And the real challenge is how do you identify the optimal
neoantigens for each patient? And I should highlight that the
MHC repertoire in all of us is highly diverse.
It's the most diverse part of our genomes.
So each of these patients has a different HLA
repertoire, and they have a different set of neoantigens that
are derived from these passengers that are private mutations often.
So we have to sift through all of that to find the right pairs.
But this was done successfully with this plan,
and what you can see are these are early cases where they can
resect the pancreatic tumor and then sequence and find the
tumor RNA and the normal, compare, find the
neoantigens, and then do the computational algorithm, which I won't go
into here, but to identify the most likely peptide
binders that would give rise to the good
projection of the mutant towards the T cell receptor.
Then formulate that into 10 to 15
different peptides in one vaccine in a lipid nanoparticle.
So this is done in this order where the
surgical resection happens here, checkpoint therapy happens at six weeks
post-surgery, then there are eight priming doses with that
personalized mRNA vaccine, and then the
chemotherapy standard of care is given for that standard regime,
and then a booster of the vaccine, and then a
follow-up. And I personally heard
the note, Balachandran speak about this a number of times, and each time I hear it,
I'm really amazed because this is grouped according
to responders and non-responders.
And in each of these columns is a patient with their
own vaccine. So this patient, for example, had
14 neoantigen mRNA-coded
vaccines in their vaccine. This one had 20.
Now, if you see any of them that have a yellow bar, those
patients,
you could find T cells to that particular peptide
in their
blood. So this patient had
seven specific ones. This one, five, five, some of them just had
one out of them. So you see how hard it is to get a really diverse
repertoire response. But these were all the responders.
They had at least one T cell specific for one of the neoantigen
peptides. And these, they could identify no T cells, and they were
not the responders. And you can see that
the relapse-free survival in the
responders is night and day from the non-responders.
So there's a lot of promise here. There were some interesting
aspects, and if you're interested in the paper, you can read why these
patients might have been particularly non-responsive.
And that was due to a particular surgical
situation. So this is, I think, for early stage,
would be really attractive.Now, what
about the case where we've got more advanced cancer?
So we might have a G12C cell line, a
cell fraction, but then at a low fraction, we might have
another allele, like I mentioned, other mutations occur, like a
G12D. We have a G12C selective inhibitor, so this
cell can be killed, but this one, because it has an
insensitive KRAS allele, cannot be killed.
So can we leverage that? Because this cell, we think
in targeted therapy, is sensitive and this one is insensitive,
we might think the game is over. But actually, they share
many common neoantigens because they were
evolved from the same truncal mutation of that prime KRAS
driver mutation. So,
how can we see if that is enough to get a complete
response?
And so the idea here is that some small fraction in this
tumor have drug resistance, and a large fraction is
drug sensitive, and we have a good molecule for that.
What happens when we do that? And this is a paper on BioRxiv
uploaded late last year from Julian Downward's lab that I
also think is really elegant. This is a
really elegant mouse model that mimics the situation that
I told you about a rare fraction of drug
resistance that shares the same common neoantigens.
So here's a G12D. It was derived from
a mouse model that had
G12D. They base edited cells to have
G12C. They also introduced mutations early
on so that there would be a low level of these
passenger mutations. Then they labeled these
G12D cells with GFP and luciferase and labeled
the sensitive cells with blue fluorescent protein.
And so now you can mix these two cells and follow the trajectories of the
sensitive and the resistant cells,
and through everything. So if you mix them together and
they grow, you can see after G12C inhibitor treatment, and
you look for the G12D cells, you see them very brightly,
as you'd expect. Okay. So, the way the
experiment's done is
he used the G12C selective
inhibitor, the approved one, adagrasib.
And as you mix cells that have G12C or G12D in
different fractions, this is 50% of the
G12D and 50% G12C, and this is
1% only G12D, 99%
G12C, 0.05, 0.01. And under
therapy, you can see you can only get a partial response
even when you started out with 0.01% of the
drug-resistant population.
And the cells all drive to the G12D
under G12C therapy,
even when you start with 15 out of 150,000 cells.
It's a pretty remarkable selection, but this is kind of why we're here.
This is the challenge that we have to overcome.
Now what Julian's lab did was overlaid that
with checkpoint therapy. Now if we get the killing by the G12C inhibitor
and we take the brakes off with the checkpoint, what
happens? There are two checkpoint-like therapies or
immune oncology therapies. One is the SHIP2 inhibitor and one is
PD-1. We'll focus on the PD-1. I think it's simpler and
results are similar. So with vehicle, each mouse takes off.
PD-1 therapy doesn't do anything.
Like I said, this doesn't have the high tumor mutation burden to let the checkpoint
inhibitor work. The G12C inhibitor alone, 1 out of
14 complete responses. So just one
time, like that waterfall plot I showed you.
So it can happen, but not very common.
But when you combine the cell killing with the allele-specific inhibitor
and the checkpoint therapy, we get almost half of the
mice have a complete response. So this really tells us
that selective killing of even a
subpopulation will alert the immune system, and with the
checkpoints, we can release the brakes and get a much better killing.
And then the last experiment they did, which I really liked, is they took each of
the complete responders in these cases,
and these mice had no tumors, couldn't find them,
and they rechallenged them with 100%
G12D. So now 100% of the complete
resistant cell population, and in one case,
it was complete immune memory and rejection,
three out of seven in this case, three out of six in this case.
So I really think
once we can see more checkpoint therapies come in with the direct
KRAS inhibitors, we'll see more complete responses.
And this is, I think, telling us why.
And to highlight the bottom line is that even though we
might have a targeted therapy to only a subset of the tumor,
because they share that common evolutionary track, they share common
passenger mutations, and those can alert the immune system to
kill the drug-resistant cells. That's what that paper
really shows, and I think the promise of that is very exciting.
So,
I'll just end. I told you about some of our G12C work.
That was John Ostrem, Ulf Peters, and my colleague Jim Wells,
and then the Araxys group, Ian Pingda.
And thank you for your attention, and we can handle a few
questions. And yeah, thank you.
And we have video, people. So, that mic
and that mic, if you have any questions.
Yeah.By
tomorrow, there'll be so many questions from people, but I know we're early in the
meeting.
Well,
I saw Silvio's slide deck, so I know we need to give him
time. So why don't we just keep moving, and we can ask questions in a more
free form?
So if we could have-
Yeah, we could do that too. That would be great.
Yeah, save questions for all of us at any time.
So Chiara Ambrogio is from University of Torino.
She trained there.
Then she did her first postdoc or
primary postdoc work with Mariano Barbacid,
and then was a senior scientist at Dana-Farber with Pasquani, and
then had a really fabulous fellowship to come back to
Italy where she started her lab, and she's been doing just
fantastic work about fundamental RAS biochemistry at the
membrane, and also a lot of integrating of a lot of these
new agents together to treat these RAS tumors. Chiara, thank you.
Thank you very much, Kevin, for the very complete introduction.
Thank you all for being here. So I will start where
Kevin stopped, and I will go a little bit deeper into intrinsic
mechanism of resistance to RAS inhibitors.
So I will just take one slide to
illustrate the very long history of
RAS that lasted four decades, from the
early '80s, where KRAS and RAS oncogenic mutation were
found in different labs more or less at the same time, Mariano Barbacid, Bob
Weinberg, Mike Wigler, Chen-Ming Der.
And then highlighting another important date, which is early
2000, where we had the first mouse models for the
study of
KRAS in physiological system that are exactly the same mouse model
that we're still studying and using heavily today.
Then, of course, highlighting discovery by Kevin Shoka group, like I
mentioned before, that really represented a revolution in
the field because these were the first molecules that were able to
directly inhibit and target
mutant KRAS, specifically G12C, for the reason that Kevin
explained before. And then all these
story that in between was,
let's say, very filled with failure of different
molecules trying to target KRAS mutant inhibitor.
But then at the end, we were successful because in 2021, thank
you to, again, the seminal discovery from Kevin's group.
We had the first two direct molecule approved for the treatment of
KRAS G12C-driven tumors, which are sotorasib and
adagrasib.
So the problem here is that, of course,
I'm quoting
Chen-Ming Der here saying that dogma is a moving target because thanks to this
discovery, we went from the concept that KRAS drug oncogene
is undruggable to finally the successful story that
now we can drug KRAS. But the problem is that not
only we dismantle the dogma and now KRAS is druggable, but
we move from the situation in 2021 with just two drugs
approved now to this situation, and this slide is not even updated and
complete. So we have growing numbers of molecules that are making
their way through different phases of clinical trials.
And not just now G12C, we have different molecules
targeting all the different
mutant isoform, mainly G12D, but now we have also pan-KRAS,
pan-RAS inhibitor, different mechanism of action, different type of
molecules. Now, this is representing, of
course, an advantage and an opportunity because as we learn how
to use the first two drugs that are approved, we are also learning,
unfortunately, that they are developing resistance pretty fast.
And in the last, I would summarize, four or five years of
intense research in the preclinical and clinical space, we can
now summarize the
type of resistance to KRAS inhibitors in three main categories.
We have intrinsic resistance. This is mainly due to the work of Fernando
Scolitis at MD Anderson, but also many others, where we
have KEAP1, SMARCA4, and CDKN2N,
that they are concomitant alteration together with KRAS
G12C in primary tumors, and they are now considered as major
independent determinants of inferior clinical outcome of KRAS
G12C monotherapy.
Then we have the classical category of acquired alteration, and
this is following very close the experience that we had in the past with
EGFR or ALK driven tumors, where we have
either the selection of in cis alteration in the
binding site of the oncogene that is giving resistance to
the drug. And in the case of KRAS, these are residues
95, 96, 68 that are impairing the binding with
either sotorasib or adagrasib. So basically, the drug
is not binding any longer to the pocket that Kevin was mentioning before,
and they are easily escaping drug pressure.
Or we can have the selection of preexisting clones with increased fitness
on drug treatment and expressing other type of mutation,
either on pathway in the MAP kinase pathway or in parallel pathways
or even de novo alteration. And then we have a third category
of resistance, which is adaptive resistance, which is a
little bit more elusive and difficult to study, specifically in patients,
not that much in preclinical model, but in patient, yes, because these are not
due to the acquisition of genomic alteration,
but they are due to,
let's say, rewiring of the transcriptional pathway or
synthesis of GTP-bound KRAS or adaptive
reactivation of wild-type RAS, and this is mainly work done by Pirolito
and Sloan Kettering in New York. So if we take into
consideration all this huge variety of type of resistance
plusThe number of molecules that we can use now,
you can easily see that this equation is giving a number
of potential therapeutic strategies requiring validation that is high
exceeding the number of clinical trials that we could
do. And this is a nice example, I think, about how
preclinical and clinical work could really dialogue and find a
way to rationalize how we can test now all these new
molecules that they are really fast approaching
the end of their journey towards approval.
So, I will just give you in this talk, for example,
about how to rationalize all of these, and as a disclosure, I
won't touch anything about non-autonomous features.
Some of these immunological related features that Kevin already
mentioned, and some that we will hear after.
So I will just talk about pure tumor intrinsic cases.
So
the four cases that I would like to very briefly see with you are
conventional
coupling with upstream or downstream
therapies together with KRAS mutation in upfront settings,
so in naive tumor. Can we move from monotherapy to combined
therapy in order to have prolonged and best effect
on KRAS mutant tumors? Or in the case where we have
acquired alteration in CIS, like I'm mentioning before.
These tumors that they are mutating in codons that are 95
or 96 or 68, which is again, making them no
longer able to bind with the drug. They are still
exquisitely MAP kinase dependent, so how can we hit harder on
the same pathway in order to achieve a response?
Or in case, like I mentioned before, still in the category of acquired
alteration, in case these tumors, they acquire something else outside the MAP
kinase pathway. Is this druggable or not?
Can we combine treatment in this case?
Or also the last category, how can we really deal with
adaptive resistant context in preclinical
situation and in patients as well?
So I will present my slides all in the same way, very consistent, so you can easily
follow. So all what I'm presenting is in vivo, and then I will just
put references for whatever it is published in the literature so you can
follow up. Starting from the first case, so which is combining
KRAS inhibitor with upstream or downstream inhibitor.
I just put here two cases. In the case of upstream, it
is a combination for KRAS G12D, in this case,
inhibitors with upstream SOS1 inhibitor, or a case
where KRAS G12C, it is coupled with downstream MEK
inhibitors. So in both cases, let's start with the first one.
We see that this is in vivo animal models and waterfall plot
and an example of extract from tumors.
You see the combination, it is indeed working very well, as well
as combining with downstream targets.
In this case, it's MEK inhibitor. You see that the combination is by far
the best one in this context. So these are just two example.
This is pretty, let's say, intuitive situation
where we can find in a naive setting how to hit harder
starting from the very beginning with upstream or downstream.
This study is also referenced to clinical trials that are ongoing, and you
see that there are many other publication or studies combining
different targets. So other than SOS1, you can use SHP2 inhibitor,
CDK4/6, farnesyltransferase inhibitor, and in the majority of
these publication that you can check, there is superiority
in combination compared to monotherapy alone.
Moving to the second case, where we could model
this in cis alteration in codon 95 and
96. We know, as I mentioned before, that these tumors, they are
still very much dependent on MAP kinase pathway.
So we ask whether this could be a setting where we could test
new MEK inhibitors, and in this case, we test a clamp inhibitor that
is inhibiting at the same time MEK and reactivation
from upstream CRAF together with a FAK inhibitor.
And we saw that in this case, timing is very important
because in early phases of treatment, you
see that the majority of this treatment is achieving a very nice
response, but then in long run, the
combination that were working better is combination with
indeed avotamib, which is the clamp inhibitor plus upstream
FAK inhibitor. And also in this case, there are clinical trials,
and the important thing to mention here is that MAP kinase pathway is still
actionable in this tumor, but obviously, and for sake of time
not showing here, you can easily imagine that these tumors, they are still
very nicely responding to second and third generation
inhibitors. So the new RASON inhibitors, they are still very
active against this type of secondary mutation in CIS with
G12CWhat can we
do in case resistant tumors, they are developing mutations that are
outside the MAP kinase pathway or that in any case that can be considered
druggable? In this case, what we did, we
took,
let's say, inspiration from the early work from Mark Awad in
tumor resistant to adagrasib, and we noticed that a good fraction of these
patients, they were developing fusions, fusion with ALK.
So, this was an interesting case for us because this was exactly
represented what can we do in case we identify a
secondary mutation that is potentially druggable, but we don't know
how and when we can combine with KRAS inhibitor.
So we model these tumors, so tumors expressing both KRAS
G12C and EML4-ALK fusion. And as expected, this
tumor, they are completely insensitive to either single agent
alone. So KRAS inhibitor in red, you see here, ALK inhibitor,
alectinib, in green here, but they are nicely responding to
combination of these two inhibitor.
Even more interesting, because this could be, again, some sort of intuitive,
discussing with our clinical colleagues, they told us that this is not the
real clinical scenario because this patient, they
do not express both oncogene upfront.
They develop the secondary alteration, and in this case is ALK fusion when
they are in constant treatment with KRAS inhibitor.
So we repeated all these assay, both in vitro and in vivo, in
constant presence with adagrasib, like patients experience.
And to our great surprise, these
preclinical models, they developed single agent sensitivity to ALK
inhibitor alone, suggesting that the signaling rewiring is
plastic, and under constant pressure with KRAS inhibitors,
these tumors, they acquire complete sensitivity to ALK
signaling alone. Of course, they all see a response in very nice to the
combination therapy. So for us, this is
an interesting consideration to be done with our clinical colleagues because this
suggests that if we had biomarkers in vivo for patients, which at this
time, of course, we don't have, but we could switch from single agent KRAS
inhibitor to single agent ALK inhibitor and probably switch,
let's say, single treatment, avoiding potential toxicity from combination
therapies.
The last example, it is, to be honest, that's more
interesting to me because in this case, we were
lucky enough to be able to work with models derived directly from patients.
And what we had here were models from patients that developed resistant to
sotorasib in absence of any acquired genomic alteration.
And we were able to characterize from PDX from these patients that
these tumors, they are resistant to
sotorasib because they overexpress wild type
isoforms, so H and N, and they also have
hyperloaded GTP in the KRAS mutant
setting. So we reasoned that considering this type of
resistance, these two new molecules could be a good way for us
to try to overcome resistance. So we have the Revolution Medicine
4998, which is elacestrant, which is specifically
targeting GTP-loaded KRAS G12C. And we
also thought about testing RASmulti,
deraxone, because this is agnostic for
RAS isoform, so it is hitting H, K, and N.
Indeed, this was the case because let's start first with
elacestrant, the KRAS G12C on, and we see that indeed,
single agent treatment alone was sufficient to
control tumor growth, even though we just noticed one tumor
shrinkage in this case, and the majority were just stable disease.
But very interesting, when we tested deraxone,
we decided also in light of very new finding from
the Revolution Medicine group, and again from Piero Olito's group, to also
harness the intrinsic property of deraxone to
stimulate the intrinsic hydrolysis property of
KRAS. So which means that if this is true, this could
synergize with KRAS G12C off inhibitor, right?
And this indeed was the case. So we ran this very complete
trial where in these tumors, we add single agent
G12C off, single agent on, single agent deraxone, and
then the combination of on plus off and deraxone
plus sotorasib or plus elacestrant.
And comparing all the groups, by far, the best
treatments were the multi RAS in combination with off, which is very
likely suggesting that indeed you have these two hit function.
You just stimulate the intrinsic hydrolytic property of
KRAS, and then you go and hit with the off inhibitor back.
And also the multi RAS plus the G12C on, which is very
likely, like recently published in Cancer Discovery by the
RevMed group, it is hitting independent pools of
mutant RAS. And this is, again, also ongoing, and you see
a lot of literature published in that and still
more literature coming because I think that this is a very interesting
topic. So
I would just like to finish with a consideration that, of course, this is a very
schematic and oversimplified vision because
even in this effort that we try in preclinical setting, of
course, each of these question could be done in reciprocal models.
So of course, we could test RAS on inhibitor in
secondary mutation, and maybe this is working or maybe it's not.
We can test better MEK inhibitor in the context of adaptive
resistance. So that's why even in preclinical setting,
it is heavy work to be done. So can you easily imagine how it is
important to prioritize what can we really test in patient.
And there is more to come because the final concept is that KRAS
degraders, they are really coming, and they are very interesting.
So of course, then the question would be, whenever we will have
patients or tumors resistant to KRAS inhibitor, whenever
degraders will be available, is this going to be relevant or not just
for on-target alteration or is it going to be another way
to, let's say, overcome resistant andHow this
will impact on the equation that I show at the very beginning, it will make
things more complicated or not. Shall we think about sequential
treatment, third, second line, or combine again upfront?
So this, of course, is an open question. I don't have the answer yet.
Hopefully, very soon. This was my last slide.
So I thank very much all the collaborators that helped me in
the journey, and happy to take the question very likely at the
end, right? We have Silvio first, and then... Okay.
So hold your question, and then we will have a joint Q&A at the
end of the session. Thank you very much.
All right. So,
thank you, Chiara. That was fantastic.
The next speaker, Silvio Gutkind from UC San Diego.
He did his early training in Buenos Aires through his PhD,
and he came to the NIH, where
he
rose through the ranks from a fellow to head of a division.
And his discoveries on finding mutations in
heterotrimeric G proteins in uveal melanoma and other head and
neck situations were really pioneering to tell us
about those oncogenes, as well as viral genes that have
similar functions. And then, 10 years ago, I believe,
he came to UCSD. He's now chair of pharmacology, and
please. Thank you.
Thank you, Evan, for the wonderful introduction, and so this will be
different. With a different accent, by the way.
So what I will try to do today, so first, my disclosures.
I will not be discussing today, so the most important, I'm a
immunologist in training, so anything I say is
right, thanks to my colleagues. Anything I say is wrong, it's just me. Okay?
Though this time I will have limited amount of immunology.
So you heard a lot about K-RAS already in RAS oncogenes.
That was one of the first human oncogenes
discovered. I will focus a little bit more into
using as an example here, melanoma.
This is like the poster child of precision medicine.
So all the way from the discovery of mutations in BRAF in
patients, all the way to the first FDA-approved
treatment targeting this BRAF mutation was only nine
years. That is amazing. And you can tell this is
just-- If you see the patients, the response to this
treatment,
in only three months, you can see they are clean
of cancer. That would be wonderful.
Just eight more weeks, and the patient
relapse, and quite often they will succumb.
There are other lines of treatment, but usually will succumb to disease.
That is the example I want to use to reflect what
Chiara was referring to, the process of resistance.
And we already went into the-- She explained very nicely
intrinsic resistance, acquired, and adaptive resistance.
So to keep it simple, I will focus primarily in adaptive
resistance, given that the data so far is more related to
signaling, and which is more aligned with also with our
expertise. So for BRAF mutations,
the most typical signaling
event is the rewiring of the different pathways
leading to an enhanced activation of ERK. It's the most typical.
And there are also vertical and horizontal mechanisms
resulting in resistance as well as changes in
cell state, like mesenchymal state.
What I will try to do right now, first, is
remind ourself that the first
aspect of the resistance can be handled.
You can add what is called vertical inhibition.
So you add the BRAF mutant
inhibitor, and then you add a MEK inhibitor.
Toxicities do emerge, of course, you can imagine, but that is
FDA approved, for example, for the three different treatment options.
Just to give you a sense, that's doable, and yet all of these patients
will also, at some point, very likely relapse.
Where we'll focus specifically is
in the Hippo-YAP/TEAD pathway. Probably is
much less understood. It was discovered only a few years ago,
primarily by DJ Pan in Drosophila,
based on the overgrowth of the eye and different organs.
And Kun-Liang Wang, when he was at UCSD, dissected the underlying
mechanisms of these pathways. Keeping it simple,
the idea, so the core Hippo pathway is just two kinases, two
complexes of kinases,
MST1 and Salvador, LATS combined with MOB1.
These two kinases, usually in the off state when
they are not active, when cells need to proliferate, it will
enable a
coactivator called YAP and the brother,
or cousin, TAS
to go to the nucleus, bind transcription factors of the TEAD family, there
are four, TEAD1, 2, 3, and 4, and induce expression of genes
important for proliferation and survival.
When cells touch to each other, and by the way, that's the
principle, the transformation, the focus formation
with RAS, for example.
To override the cell-to-cell, cell
contact inhibition, you do need to get YAP
being active. So that is a primary function.
So when
cells contact each other, they know they are touching each other, they activate the
Hippo pathway, and that leads to the sequestration of TAB, TAZ,
and YAP from the nucleus, and in many cases, also
degradation.There are many inputs, mostly in the cell
surface, similar to receptor tyrosine kinases, GPCRs,
but many sensing the cells are touching each other.
So that's the primary function. And what I will try to explain,
this maybe an adaptive activation of Hippo-Yap/Tead pathway
can be a mechanism of resistance. That will be what is the
mechanisms first, and is it druggable?
And what I will try to explain this in the context of targeted therapies briefly.
Most of these are
unpublished, by the way,
in uveal melanoma and melanoma for targeted therapies and immune
therapies in the context of head and neck cancer.
So
let me explain a little bit about uveal melanoma. You may not be that familiar.
There are very few cases, 2,500 new cases a year in the US.
Instead of BRAF mutations, they have activation of, and
Keyvan was mentioning, so particularly a G protein called G alpha Q
or 11, which is the brother.
92% will have mutations.
The immune therapies don't work in general.
Most targeted therapies don't work.
And 50% of these patients will progress and develop metastasis to
the liver. Once metastasis occur,
usually survival is extremely limited.
So
why it's important? First, because there are patients that need our
contributions, but at the same time, this is relatively clean
cancer. Keyvan was showing you the distribution of the different
mutational landscape of all of the cancers.
Uveal melanoma will be at the very far, in my case, right.
So there are five, six mutations only, so it's very stable.
Very few mutations, and hence is not recognized by the immune system as
well. So it makes it easier to try to investigate the
mechanism because we have low mutational burden and limited
tumor heterogeneity. So the classical pathway
GQ activates ERK certainly similar to
BRAF, you use an ERK inhibitor, it just doesn't work.
Many clinical trials, one way or another, MEK inhibitors
decrease the quality of life of the patients, do not improve
the survival of the patients. So there may be something else is
there. That is where we jump into being the fact that it's a G
protein, and we contributed to the discovery of the G protein long time
ago as an oncogene. We start doing
many different approaches to identify how really it works.
And I will just glance the titles in the cartoons to keep it
simple. In the first, using genome-wide screens, what we found
that in addition to PLC beta, PKC, and ERK, you
also need to activate a Rho exchange factor called Trio.
And then you activate Rho, and that was central to the ability to
transform. Furthermore,
many of the hits in the screen, we couldn't make any sense.
We have no idea what we're talking about.
And so reading and contacting Kuliang Wan, so we figured out
many of them were really in the Hippo pathway, and we were able to show,
Cancer Cell gave us the, here's the little Hippo, Hippito.
They were able to show us. So the
Hippo pathway was central using different approaches,
shRNAs, and this, and that, and that,
to initiate uveal
melanoma driven by GQ. That's really cool, very important.
So it's a distinct pathway we call non-canonical.
We also collaborated with other groups to show Trio binds and
grabs GQ, so we solve the crystal structure, and that's really cool.
But it's not druggable for the time being.
And so
doing a computational approach with our colleague, Etan Rubin,
when he was at NIH, recently he left,
and Sid Saina,
we were able to identify a synthetic lethal interaction all based on RNA
sequencing, and is this protein called FAK
that Chiara was just mentioning, or is a non receptor
tyrosine kinase, was central to the ability to
induce proliferation but also was central to the activation of
YAP. And
due to tyrosine phosphorylation of YAP, phosphorylation of one component of
the core Hippo kinase. That's excellent because now we can target
it. So there is a drug that we can use as we collaborate in
similar with Abeta Stem that developed the first
FAK inhibitor. But instead of running into clinical trial, we
run into CRISPR screens, because needless to
say, we did not expect FAK inhibitors to be the answer.
So what we did is to run a CRISPR screen to identify mechanisms of resistance,
mechanism downstream, and the overall, no surprises here
perhaps, we should have known it. The other
arm of the GQ pathway is the mechanism of resistance
and also the mechanism that you need to combine both in order to
achieve a clinical or at least pre-clinical response.
So we brought this to the clinic,
in collaboration with Vera Stem, using abotulimab
specifically. It's the same one that Chiara was mentioning.
And
to some extent,
we achieved some interesting responses, promising.
The trial was
only a few patients. We have a signal that may be possible,
but the reality is the tumor did not shrink much, if any.
So the patients survive probably longer.
The paper is being just submitted, probably will be out soon.
But we figured out that something was not quite right, and probably what was not
quite right, it was not the CRISPR screen of the concept.
It probably what was not right is the MEK inhibitor.
And I will go into cutaneous melanoma, why that may be important.
Abotulimab is the one we use. We should have used probably something else.
At that time, we have no idea. So in that aspect, we start
looking for a mechanism, another drug, another approach.In
collaborating with Craig Thomas at NCI,
we ran a huge screen, what we call chemogenetic
screen, to identify new drug targets.
And the winner, by far, was a molecule at that time known as
LX196, now it's called darovassartib, that
was proposed to be PKC inhibitor, which makes sense
because PKC is very important. However, in the clinic, prior
studies with PKC inhibitors did not work in the clinic.
Classical PKC inhibitors were very
low in our list of hits. So something was
special about this drug. So don't read only
what's published. So what we did, collaboration with Dario Alessi, he has
been in Dundee. He has the best way to monitor different
kinases. We did a kinome analysis, and we found that
not only blocks all PKCs, canonical, non-canonical, but also
PKN. And PKN is a kinase, is sort of a
PKC-like downstream from Rho. So we went back to
square one. Again, Rho, Trio in the pathway was very
important. Only this drug can block part of the PKN,
part of this pathway diminishes a little bit temporarily
YAP, but it targets both.
Very fortunate for the patients. Three days ago, four days
ago,
Idyllia, the company, I have no shares, no conflicts.
Idyllia,
so the company, they're developing darovassartib,
reported the first clinical trial in combination with crisotinib in the
context of metastatic uveal melanoma.
So it
seems to be a positive response. The patients live longer,
or at least they
increase progression-free survival.
The survival of the patient is still not there yet.
That said , considering this is a positive trial, if you
see the patients, the progression-free survival is extended by two, three
months. Okay? So it's
wonderful, difficult to say this is a success in the terms we have
not cured this cancer yet. And that answer, what is the mechanism of
resistance now of this combination?
If you see carefully, blocks this, blocks that,
but still a long way to go to YAP. And that is precisely,
I will very simple.
In only 24 hours after adding darovassartib, very simple
experiments. If you run RNA sequencing, typical YAP
target genes go up. Very quickly, adaptively, they
induce activation of YAP targets.
This poster will be presented on Monday, so I will not go
all the details done, and Elena and, sorry, Sophia,
they are here in the audience.
So we'll be presenting, go to the poster.
What is exciting that now finally there are TED inhibitors.
There were no RAS inhibitor for a long time.
Thanks you guys, especially Kimon.
And now TED inhibitors now there are many.
So initially, Vivaeq was the first company they start developing, but there are
many TED inhibitors targeting TED, particularly has an
auto-permeation site, needs to permeate itself.
And this is the most advanced of the
TED inhibitors. There are many others.
This recently was reported in "Nature Medicine" that have
potential beneficial effects in NF2 mutant
mesothelioma patients with tolerable toxicities.
So basically now we can use, besides many other manipulations, knockdown,
knockouts, et cetera, we can use TED inhibitors.
And I would just summarize in a little bit.
So use different TED inhibitors. You enhance
apoptosis induced by darovassartib.
Absolutely beautiful synergistic.
So I call synergy is when one plus one
equal 11, okay? That's beautiful.
And when you combine in mouse patients, sorry,
you see that there is tumor reduction in many of the
tumors, whereas each one of the agents alone, darovassartib or the
TED inhibitor is mostly cytostatic.
Also in models for metastasis, you can see an increase in
survival of the mice.
So
mechanistically, perhaps this is relevant to the comments
about why it happens. Mechanistically, and you can go to the poster,
what we found is that ERK controls the expression of
a molecule called RND3 that encodes a protein
called RhoE, and RhoE is a suppressor,
blocks Rho. So if you anytime you reduce
ERK, you reduce RND3, RhoE,
you activate Rho. So basically at the end, that's mechanistically very
clear in that you can target that with the resistant with the
TED inhibitor. Can we apply this to cutaneous melanoma?
This is where we started. And the answer is beginning to.
So here is a paper we just published.
Our first paper in cutaneous melanoma was just published
last year in collaboration with the Virastem group,
John and Silvia. What we did is, using RNA sequencing
from patients in this case, very early during the treatment, try to
capture this window where the primary driver is
adaptive resistant prior further mutations.
And very early in the, so four, five days, one week after treatment,
the patients, if you look into RNA sequencing, there's a
typical signature of we call focal adhesion.
Makes a lot of sense going back that FAK, focal
adhesion kinase, will be activated.
So and that's the case using trametinib,
vemurafenib, or this particular drug, avotamgenib.
We always see FAK, phospho-FAK, going up relatively
quicklyFor practical
purposes, this is the adaptive activation of FAK.
Now going to the same concept is induced, it's
all in the paper, you can find this, through the repression of RhoE
again. So basically, this is seen to be the general mechanism
leading to activation of FAK and later to activation
of YAP.
Now explaining why it works in this particular drug that we
use, avotamgenib, it works much better than we even expected.
Even in
patient-derived
tumors, even in cells that were coming from patients that
were resistant to
the MEK inhibitors or RAF inhibitors,
what we saw is that this drug was much, much more potent.
And the rationale is extremely simple because it's not really
just a kinase inhibitor, it's a glue.
So we call it GLAMP. It's a glue, binds together RAF with
MEK. And that,
as Chiara was just mentioning, prevents the reactivation
of ERK. What is exciting also now going to RAS is
that this combination
of FAK inhibitor and avotamgenib was recently approved
for KRAS mutant low
serous
ovarian cancer. It's relatively safe.
Trials are open based on this work on melanoma patients
that develop brain metastasis.
And hopefully, we will know the answer to the
activity.
What is exciting also, it's active in NRAS-mutant melanoma,
that can be an alternative.
And many of these properties are coming from the ability
to sequester the BRAF and the MEK.
It binds both together, whereas MEK inhibitors change the
conformation of MEK, prevent RAF activation, this one will bind them
together in an active conformation.
So what is the mechanism of resistance now?
Well, this work is done by Gabriela,
so it's still early, if you will.
It's not very quickly. It
takes a few
weeks when the tumors begin to develop a resistance.
This particularly is again, the activation of the Hippo pathway.
So that would be the primary mechanism of resistance.
And if you-- All this combination, but also a BRAF
inhibitors is also the mechanism.
And you can combine, again, different cells with
an inhibit combined synergistic
combination of the
MEK inhibitor, RAF MEK plus FAK, combined with
the TID inhibitors. And to
finishing, although
I was told that I can extend a little bit. Yeah. Perfect.
So
I will go into some new data, relatively surprising,
is that when we looked into this, many of the genes that go up in
response to YAP, it expression of certain
chemokines, CXCL1, CXCL8,
CXCL5. What the heck?
That may be a mechanism that may contribute to a
resistance. And to address that, because our expertise in head and
neck cancer, we've switched now from melanoma to head and neck cancer.
Head and neck cancer is the sixth most prominent cancer in the world,
with many cases. For practical purposes, there are two types, HPV
negative and HPV positive. HPV negative is
mostly caused by tobacco, quite often when
combined synergistically with alcohol.
Message, don't smoke. Okay? And if you
drink, don't smoke, okay? That's the message.
And these are the most aggressive and usually the worst prognosis.
So there are many mutations, 500, 600 mutations, very highly
mutated, but you can aggregate it in only few
pathways.
Cell cycle deregulation, the Notch pathway, and I will explain in a second,
the fat one leading to Hippo pathway, and the
PI3 kinase, AKT, and TOR pathway, including some few
cases of HRAS mutations. We have been focused for a long
time, PI3 kinase, AKT pathway, leading many clinical trials,
many of which were successful or contributed to ongoing
clinical trials. For practical purposes, this was exciting,
something that did not work.
So we couldn't recapitulate initiation of head and neck cancer
by mutations PI3 kinase with any of these agents.
With p53, p67, et cetera. And so
based on this failure, we just looked into the neighbor,
and then we realized that we were missing the Hippo pathway.
So actually, our paper suggested in 2018 the FAT1 is
a component of the Hippo pathway leading to activation of YAP in
most head and neck cancers. And that we did is something simple, and
it is published, and
go fast through this. Farhood, using a
highly complex combination of genes with
p67 and combined with YAP. What we found in a
temporally controlled fashion, we found that YAP induces very quickly and
combined with p67
head and neck cancer. This is really aggressive cancers.
This is not just a bump. And using this approach, we were able to do
single-cell sequencing,
and really for the first time, understand the process of conversion
from premalignancy to cancer in a very
well-controlled fashion. For practical purposes, the part I will
address is the YAP alone induces many features
in cancer initiation.But the one that we absolutely did not
expect controls immune evasion. So basically,
it recruits myeloid cells that
enable to evade the immune system,
and at the same time initiates
invasion. And so more recently, if there are
any editors in the audience, please, hey,
this is unpublished, but we want to publish soon.
We did much more complex
combinations, and again, we saw the
cancer cells release chemokines that recruit these
neutrophil-like cells, they are labeled by Ly6G,
and these are the ones that prevent the cytotoxic T cells from attacking.
And for practical purposes, you can see we're using spatial transcriptomics that
the Yap-positive cells that are
in
here are expressing
in blue. You can see very quickly,
the epithelial cells expressing CXCL1 and recruiting
immune cells. We are following this up for the paper,
almost done,
using spatial transcriptomics, and we can define clusters of
Yap positive next to these myeloid cells.
And now going into something very exciting,
we have developed a very exciting
carcinogen-induced engineered
animal models of oral cancer. They have the 93.9%
similarity with the human mutanome.
20% of the mice will be responding similar to the humans.
If you use the TID inhibitors, what you see very clear, they increase
the survival of the patient combined with anti-PD-1.
But if you looked into the immune aspects, you see CD8 T cells
that were excluded from the tumor now being able to
enter the tumor and kill the cancer cells, whereas before you see primarily
these myeloid suppressor cells. So brief summary,
activation of Hippo pathway may, in effect, may represent mechanism
of adaptive resistance for any approach
that targets the RAS/RAF/MEK/ERK pathway.
The mechanism is primarily through this RND3-ROE
signaling loop, leading to ROE activation and
Hippo/TID.
The alternative cell mechanism resistance,
Chiara was mentioning,
and perhaps surprised, in addition to oncogenesis in the network,
Hippo/ Yap/TID may also represent a immunescape
driver, and the idea is that we don't know how to combine this
and prevent maybe during the discussions in a preemptive
fashion to prevent the acquisition of resistance or revert,
overcome the resistance, and certainly we need biomarkers
and the potential for combination of TID with ICB, with immune
checkpoint.
For any in the audience, no matter where you are in the spectrum of
clinic,
the
academia, industry,
postdoc, graduate student, well-established scientist,
opportunity for partnership to advance next-gen
precision targeted immune therapies
to achieve enhanced responses, durable responses, and
we can call cancer remission or cure.
And we just glance here, this is our team.
What I wanted, and many collaborators, certainly in funding agencies,
thanks to everybody.
Key message, if you have a chance, go to
Mission Bay, wonderful for kayaking.
Just a suggestion.
It's very nice.
And this is few days ago, celebrating with our lab, our first
10 years at UCSD.
And these are our junior members, so they're
hopefully soon. Perfect. Thank you.
We have a few minutes for questions if there are any
left. Yeah.
Very interesting with all these combinations to prevent or
treat
resistance. But
do we know about all those drugs that are not
targeting mutations on their effect on immune
system cells? Would they be
also altering the immune response as well as the
functioning of the tumor cell?
I
start giving a shot to this. So this align to what Kevin was
saying. So if you have a drug that's very specific for a mutation,
you may be altering the cancer cells and kill the cancer cells,
and the cancer cells will expose all of these neoantigens that were hidden inside,
and it will be enhancing the response.
So that said, if you use even very selective BRAF mutation
specific inhibitors, they still compromise the response to
the immune therapies. And quite often, so it's a little bit of
what we call the sequencing or in terms of treatment
sequencing, the non-sequencing limitations.
So that it's usually after initial treatment with the BRAF inhibitors,
you cannot do concomitant. Usually, the treatment with BRAF, then
you need to wait then to do the immune checkpoints.
But in general,
the key is to identify something will only work into the cancer
cells but not in the immune cells. Going to the TID inhibitors, and I
transfer to you guys.
In the TID inhibitors, our initial observations, we
don't see too much of an effect into the immune.
So we are using also viral models for T cell
exhaustion, so we have many other models to test that.
We don't see an effect. If you use BRAF inhibitors, for example,
or even abemaciclibYou may have an impact.
So that's why you can do the experiment, and hopefully it will be
reflected. Mice are mice, not patients, but will be reflected.
You summarized everything that I was thinking of, but
also maybe the T cell exhaustion is a thing that people have looked at a lot.
MEK inhibitors to try to kill the tumor, but then also
keep the T cells from getting exhausted, although that trial, as I understand,
was negative. But there's some maybe
approach to keep T cells from getting exhausted, even if it does inhibit T
cell signaling a bit. Yeah. Thank you for the question.
Hi, Tim Lai, WashU. Fantastic session.
One conundrum in hematopoietic malignancies is that the RAS mutations occur
late and frequently at their acquisition.
The sub clones that are affecting hematopoiesis are incredibly small,
which raises the question of the cell autonomous effects of these RAS mutant
cells. Any thoughts about that going forward and whether they'll
contribute to resistance mechanisms?
I really don't know, but that's a great area.
I mean, the non-cell autonomous field effect is
fascinating. I wish I knew more about it. It's a great question.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for these great talks. Very stimulating.
Out of curiosity, what happen if you knock down completely the
Hippo- Yap pathway?
Why is it
there? I
mean
to expect toxicities, I think probably elaborating on that would be good.
So, I'm
a pharmacologist by training, and a
pharmacologist will tell you all depends on the dose.
So similar to the MEK inhibitors or
if you go back to rapamycin, so you don't use doses that you achieve
a complete responses. So the key is that the
cancer or itself, like in the NF2
mutant or when prompted, triggered by another
drug that forces to be dependent, is the dependency of the
cancer the one that drives the ability to use
doses that will have limited impact into
the normal cells. That's why. So I don't think the knockout is viable.
I don't think that
complete blockade of the TID will be feasible.
But the fact that the cancers are dependent is what
enables at the right dose to achieve meaningful clinical
responses. So that said, after all of this,
so the possibility is also
that
with the TID inhibitors,
probably what you need to think is during development is very well known.
But what is it doing in normal life?
So normal life basically in adults, the primary
role is to maintain part of the epithelial cells, of course, because they
proliferate, et cetera. But in principle, in my mind, this
oversimplifying is very important for wound healing.
So what we think is happening is that when you have a wound, the
cells I mentioned to you, the key role is the cell-to-cell, cell growth, a
contact, cell growth inhibition.
If you have a wound, you don't have boundaries.
The cells need to proliferate and expand.
So we'll assume that that would be an issue that we need to be careful when we're
studying, and we think that that is the rationale why
Yap induced expression of the chemokine that recruit
neutrophils or myeloid cells because you need to kill the
bacteria and whatever during the wound.
So this is why we are investigating this carefully, because in
the neoadjuvant setting, probably you want to include that prior to
surgery, and so you don't want to compromise surgery.
So the side effects
from the Divaci drug, the primary side effect is in
the kidney dysfunction,
primarily because the normal glomeruli, they detach a little bit and
they have proteinuria, and it's reversible.
And usually it takes three, four months of treatment, and it's reversible.
And so they are avoiding that by having a holiday in terms of
using the drug. This is what I'm trying to say.
And I think with avotamgenib, I think they use
for three weeks on, one week off, for example.
So that you can figure out based on PK/PD ways
to achieve the benefit of the drug without compromising the normal
functions, the normal biology.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks for a wonderful session. I had a question about the temporal
nature of the acquisition of acquired resistance mutations,
which anyone could comment on, but I think touches on Dr.
Ambrogio's presentation. Do you have a sense or any
insights on how early we should be sequencing patients for
acquired resistance mutations?
Just wondering if you think that there's an early time
period that might be relevant to start looking.
Well, different question. If you're asking me about timing, of course, I would say
that in a clinical setting, it will make sense when they relapse.
I don't think that you can detect. Of course, very low allelic frequency,
you can start detecting as early as you can check,
for example, circulating DNA. But I would say that in
a realistic clinical scenario, patients there are just tested when they
are relapsing. So I think that this is the time that is
the right one.
Thanks.
I was going to ask similar question.
I mean, but now that we have paired-end sequencing, such deeper
sequencing
Have people gone back to cases where we thought it was acquired,
but then deep sequencing told us, no, it was there, but at very
low allele frequency and-
Not that I am aware.
Okay.
No studies are published. Of course, it will make sense as we
are progressing in technology. Of course, we know also the study that you
presented from Julian Downward. It is enough as
.01% of cells, you can easily think
that this is true also on allelic frequency.
So yeah, of course. This is the always limitation whenever we present
study like this, that our clinical colleagues are saying this is easy to model in
mice, and this is also easy to check, but we should find a
realistic way to test-
Yeah
... for resistance when they are obvious from a-
Standard way to keep.
So I have a question for both of you.
So what can you use this, going to melanoma, 20% of
the patients have NRAS mutations.
So we found that just by chance or as a control, we use
NRAS mutant assuming the abemaciclib plus FAK will not work, and
actually works very well, probably because it's sequestering BRAF
access to KRAS.
So it's NRAS.
So do you know any of these inhibitors will work on the
NRAS?
Yeah. For sure the multiras is working on NRAS mutation as
well. So-
Yeah
... this is for sure the other one that we know that is working.
I don't know where there are other selective inhibitors.
Yeah.
There's only a couple emerging NRAS inhibitors
in the switch two pocket. One from MD Anderson was published recently, but
the best one that is in the clinic is that Diraxant rasopit's,
HNN-
Good
... and should cover the particular NRAS allele. Yeah.
Yeah. And would you use that alone as a single agent, or would you use
with abemaciclib and defucinib?
I don't know if
it's been in any patients that have NRAS driven. That'd be really...
Yeah.
I'll try to find out.
Yeah, because many patients, they have NRAS mutations.
So for example,
you can say for example, mucosal melanoma is a rare disease.
Quite often is familiar, so based on baseline
mutations. So in other words, they are
similar to uvea melanoma, so they are very low mutational burden.
And so maybe this can be also test case for the-
That's a great point. Yeah. That's an extremely good population for that.
Because you don't have the acquisition of resistance by, because
baseline mutational burden in
preexistent, and certainly ability to acquire may be compromised.
Yeah.
Some...
I thought a thread of both of your talks were the
MEK inhibitors being quite interesting.
It seems like there's a
bit of a resurgence and appreciation of different MEK inhibitors
now, so it's fascinating. MEK inhibitors were almost the
first kinase inhibitors we knew of.
Yeah.
And then to see each of the clinical versions and have them be glues
and things. So it's a good lesson, I think, for the
pharmacology of compounds, and to not
treat each one the same, and to try to understand them, and find the
contexts. It's-
This way, we did our initial trial.
We said it's another MEK inhibitor.
Yeah.
Whatever.
But the reality is then that may be the rationale probably why it's less
active in the GNAQ, whereas in the BRAF context is
probably much more active because I didn't show, so we have the
movie with the RAF in the MEK, and it's really beautiful how
this
form a complex, and is a relatively stable complex.
Yeah.
So.
Yeah. That's probably a good thing for the students and postdocs to keep an eye on
it. I feel like there's a lot more protein complexes
than we think of, and there's also more molecules that
stabilize them. So these are getting to be fascinating,
emerging of the structure, the chemistry-
Mm
... the cancer. So,
well, thank you all for coming to the first session, or this session, and
enjoy the meeting.